بحدث اليوم الزياره التي اجراها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الاكياف قبل ان يزور
بولندا ما هي الرساله التي يريد
ايصالها معنا من كاف عماد ابو الرب وهو
رئيس المركز الاوكراني للتواصل والحوار
اهلا وسهلا بك الرساله الرئيسيه من خلال
هذه الزياره لبيدن نحن هنا والرساله موجهه
مضمونه الوصول مباشره الى الرئيس الروسي
بالتاكيد تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين
بالتاكيد هي رساله بدايه للرئيس الروسي ان
ما ارادته وهدفت اليه روسيا من احتلال
اوكرانيا وتغيير قيادتها السياسيه وفرض
الامر الواقع على اوكرانيا وعلى العالم
فشل فشلا ذريعا الان اوكرانيا دوله ذات
سياده الان اوكرانيا استطاعت ان تحمي
مواطنينها وتستقبل ضيوفها على هذا المستوى
الرفيع وتكون الزياره في العاصمه في قلب
العاصمه في هذا التوقيت اضافه الى الرسائل
للشعب الاوكراني الشعب الاوكراني الذي
عانى من هذه الحرب ان امريكا لن تترك
وانها ترحب بخياره البحث عن الديمقراطيه
والحريه وايضا الثقه في قيادته السياسيه
والعسكريه اذا هي رسائل متعدده وان كان
ايضا فيها كذلك وعود بحزمه عسكريه جديده
كمعدات عسكريه لدعم اوكرانيا في هذه
العاصمه والتوقيت له رمزيه اختيار هذا
التوقيت بالذات ذكرى الثوره البرتقاليه مع
اقتراب موعد الذكرى الاولى لبدايه الحرب
هذا التوقيت جاء في ظل سقوط اكثر من 100
ضحيه تسمى المئه السماويه الذين سقطوا وهم
يدافعوا عن اراده الشعب الاوكراني نعم كان
هناك خيار للقياده التي كانت مواليه
لروسيا الرئيسيه الذي فر الى روسيا حاولت
ان تجبر المتظاهرين والمعتصمين في قلب
العاصمه كيف على الرضوخ وترك هذا الاعتصام
ولكن عندما وجدت يعني ان اعدادهم تزيد
استخدمت القوه وسطرت هذه الملحمه
التاريخيه البطوليه للاوكران فاصبحت ذكرى
سنويه معتبره وجاءت وتوافقت مع ايضا
اختيار الرئيس بايدن لهذا التوقيت
هل تعتقد ان الاوكرانيين الان على قناعه
بان الدعم العسكري الامريكي سيكون في
المستوى او بحجم ما ينتظره على الاقل ما
تنتظره القوات الاوكرانيه
انا متابع لشان المكونات المجتمع
الاوكراني بحكم ايضا عضويتي في مجلس
القوميات حكومي اضافه الى جهودنا كمركز
اوكرانيا تواصل الحوار من خلال ايضا
تشكينا للاداره الانسانيه العربيه
للمساعدات الانسانيه الحقيقه كل من وقعت
رايت وزرته في كافه المدن الاوكرانيه لم
اجد حتى اللحظه اي انقسام في الراي
المجتمع والشعب الاوكراني الكل يعتبر انه
يدافع عن وحده وسياده اراضيه الكل رغم كل
الالم على سقوط الضحايا وعلى الخسائر وغير
ذلك من امور ولكن يرى ان روسيا يعني عندما
فرضت هذه القوه العسكريه وارادت
بالتصريحات السياسيه اخافه الشعب الشعب
الاوكراني التاريخيا ناظر لاجل هذه الحريه
ولا زال يناضل كما تعلم ان بولندا ودول
البلطيق من اكثر الدول حاليا تاييد
لاوكرانيا لماذا لانها كانت مع اوكرانيا
في الحقبه السوفيتي هي تسعى
للحصول على الحريه حصل هناك خلافات
وصدامات وروسيا كانت تستطيع ان تسيطر على
القرارات في هذه الدول الان الشعب
الاوكراني يقول للعالم ويقول ايضا للناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي الذي يامل ان ينضم
اليهما انني اهل لذلك فانا ابحث عن حريتي
وابحث عن قيمة وللاسف لو كانت المعادله
سيدي العزيز ان روسيا لم تحتل الارض
الاوكرانيه لكان لنا ايضا تصريحات واراء
اخرى ولكن للاسف يعني روسيا اوصدت كباب
كبير من ابواب المجال لايجاد مناوره حتى
لكثير من الدول التي تامل ان تاخذ دور
الوساطه اذا لاحظتم شبه انعدام لوجود مسار
هيئه الامم المتحده الامم المتحده اسست في
عام 1945 فيها اكثر من 1993 عضو اين هي
خيارات وادوات الامم المتحده الحاضنه
الدوليه لحفظ السلم الامن العالمي مجلس
الامن الدولي هيئه محكمه العدل الدوليه
وغير ذلك من مؤسسات في هناك ضعف ولما اقول
انعدام للمسار التفاوضي هذا جعل اوكرانيا
تذهب الى البحث عن حلفاء حظ اوكرانيا انها
جاره للاتحاد الاوروبي حظ اوكرانيا ايضا
ان هناك مصالح كذلك تقاطعت بين مصلحه
امريكا وبريطانيا في اضعاف روسيا الناتو
او باعتقادي اوروبا وان كانوا ايضا لا
يريدوا لروسيا ان تشكل اي تهديد عليهم لكن
بنفس الوقت لم يكونوا على ذاك الخلاف
الحاد مع اوروبا بل على العكس شهدنا تعاون
اقتصادي وتكامل حتى في ملف نردس ريمي
الالماني الذي امتد ليحقق يعني ردد قوي في
مجال الطاقه لكن للاسف كل ذلك اصبح الان
يعني من التاريخ الماضي لماذا لان
الحلقه الحاليه والشعار الحالي هو انعدام
الثقه للاسف بين الاطراف سواء كان طرف
مباشر اوكرانيا روسي او حتى اطراف دوليه
دخلت في حلبه هذا الخلاف والذي نسميه
الحرب الاوكرى الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا او
الحرب غير المبرره طيب بالتاكيد الان كل
الانظار صوب الكلمه للرئيس بوتين غدا
والتي ينتظرها الجميع هل تعتقد ان هذه
الزياره والزيارات السابقه ربما زادت
الرئيس الروسي تشنجا ربما هذا الذكرى
الاولى قد تكون حاسمه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
والهجوم المنتظر قد يقع
باعتقادي بالنسبه للهجوم هو متوقع في اي
لحظه بالنسبه للرساله بالتاكيد يعني تعمد
الرئيس الامريكي ان يسبق الرئيس البوتين
في خطابه
باقامه هذه الزياره ربما لكي يشعر بوتين
ان الدول الماضيه في دعم اوكرانيا
وبالتالي ليس عليه ان يصر على هذا العناد
في عدم المرونه في مواقفه خاصه في مساله
الانسحاب او مساله اعطاء ضمانات لاوكرانيا
لكن باعتقادي كذلك ان من يفهم بوتين بوتين
القرار كما نعرف في روسيا واضح انه ليس
قرار الديمقراطي او قرار سوري كما نراه في
دول اخرى كامريكا واوروبا فبالتالي القرار
هو بشخص القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه وهو
الرئيس بوتين فبالتالي ماذا يدور في ذهنه
هل يستطيع او هل ممكن ان يراهن احد على ان
يتخذ بوتين قرار جريء مغاير لقراره السابق
في احتلال اراضي دوله جوار واعتداء على
سياده اراضيها ومحاوله تغيير قيادتها في
كييف دون ان ينجح في ذلك هل سيتخذ الرئيس
الروسي هذا القرار باعتقاد اوكرانيا اكثر
من يفهم روسيا وبالتالي هي لا تعتقد ابدا
انه سيكون هناك اي مرونه في الموقف
الرئاسي الروسي ولكنها تراهن على اما ان
يكون تغيير داخلي في القياده الروسيه او
على انها ستستطيع حسم الامر للاسف نقول في
المجال العسكري لانه ليس لديها اي خيار
سوى المجال العسكري للدفاع عن نفسها طيب
دخول مجموعه فاجنر على الخط غير المعادله
العسكريه على الارض
هو غير من حيث التاثير فقط لكن حتى بقدر
يعني هناك رصد لخسائرها التي تجاوزت
بجهات حياديه قرابه 30 الف مقاتل باغنر لا
ننسى انها لم تعد فقط تجمع الجنود
النوعيين والمهنيين والمتقاعدين من القوى
الامنيه في جيوش سواء الروسيه او غيرها
الان بدات تستعين في المسجونين والذين
عليهم تهم جنائيه كبيره فبدات تستعير بهم
لتجعلهم و قيود للحرب لكي تستنفذ اوكرانيا
ذخيرها في قصف وقتل هذه الجبهه وثم تدخل
قواتها التي لا زالت ربما باعداد اقل لكن
باعتقادي ان فاجنر نفسها واجهت واعترفت
انها واجهت مقاومه شرسه ووقع في صفها
خسائر كبيره وحتى كنا نرى ان القوات
الشيشانيه الخاصه والقوات الجيش الروسي
والان قوات كلها اتحدت ومع ذلك اختلفت في
اليه العمل كان هناك ارباك في تعاونها
ودعمها اللوجستي وحتى التصريحات
والاتهامات المتبادله بينها وامس سمعنا من
الرئيس الشيشاني للاسف انه عند النهايه
عمله المدني هو مستعد لتشكيل جبهه
او مشابهه لقوات اذا للاسف التصعيد مستمر
ولكن الواقع اوكرانيا لا زالت تدافع رغم
انها تخسر بالتاكيد الضحايا من جنودها
اضافه الى بعض المناطق الجزئيا من ارضها
عماد بن رباب شكرا جزيلا لك